[Applaudissements]
la pensée est un éclair au milieu de la
nuit mais c'est cette guerre qui est
tout cette citation et du mathématicien
nancéen henri poincaré et elle résonne
beaucoup avec l'expérience de nombreux
mathématiciens même si je n'ai jamais
rien découvert qu'ils arrivent à la
cheville des découvertes de poincaré
je pense savoir exactement de quoi point
car il parle et je suis sûr qu'il y en a
plusieurs parmi vous qui savez
exactement vous aussi de quoi poincaré
parle faire des mathématiques
c'est laborieux c'est difficile c'est
passé le plus clair de son temps à être
confus être perdus au milieu d'équations
impénétrable à se sentir incapable de
saisir l'abstraction des concepts
mathématiques
ça on l'a tous vécu c'est tous déjà
senti idiot stupide et incompétent face
à un problème mathématique et si on a un
qui osent contredire cette affirmation
exigé de lui une solution à l'hypothèse
de riemann le pire qui puisse arriver si
une avancée spectaculaire en théorie des
nombres faire des mathématiques c'est
vraiment difficile pour tout le monde
c'est explorer une grotte obscures sont
la lueur d'une bougie c'est mettre les
mains sur des objets inconnus sans
savoir s'il s'agit d'un enplus 1e
cailloux ou d'un trésor voient sans même
savoir s'il existe une façon de
déterminer s'il s'agit de l'un ou de
l'autre mais
c'est sans doute ce doute cet inconnu
cette incertitude qui rend les
découvertes mathématiques d'autant plus
savoureuse à ces découvertes
mathématiques
cet instant où tout s'illumine
cette pensée qui change tout cet éclair
qui frappe d'un coup c'est un moment
exceptionnel d'une puissance exquise à
titre personnel c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'adore faire des mathématiques
alors j'adore aussi être confus j'adore
la confusion
j'aime être perdu mais ce que j'aime
avant tout c'est cette surcharge de
dopamine qui accompagne mes découvertes
mathématiques ce moment où tout à coup
je comprend une subtilité qui
m'échappait en écoutant un enseignant un
chercheur ou un vulgarisateur ce moment
où nous encore je découvre par moi même
une vérité mathématique qui m'échappe et
jusque là y compris lorsqu'il s'agit
d'une vérité découverte par d'autres
mathématiciens parfois des millénaires
avant moi cette joie intense de la
découverte cet orgasme
pour moi c'est comme une drogue j'ai eu
la chance d'y goûter
je ne cesse de rêver d'y goûter à
nouveau et du coup ce que j'essaie
souvent de faire c'est de recréer les
conditions de mes découvertes
antérieures mais ça ça va amener à
beaucoup réfléchir à comment est-ce que
je réfléchisse qu'est ce qui fait que je
pense que je pense et comment je peux
avoir de meilleures idées
après de longues années de réflexion sur
comment je réfléchis je dois bien avouer
que j'en suis arrivé à une conclusion un
petit peu embarrassante
je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas d'où viennent les éclairs
dont parle poincaré c est clair j'en ai
vécu mais je suis aussi conscient de ne
pas être conscients de l'origine de ces
éclairs je suis même assez persuadé
aujourd'hui qu'il s'agit en fait du
fruit d'un long travail de mon
inconscient
un long travail de longue haleine
donc je suis inconscient je ne suis pas
le seul à faire ce constat
en fait c'est un constat qui semble
faire beaucoup de mathématiciens sans
que les mathématiciens n'ont pas
franchement compris comment ils
comprennent les choses
plus étrange encore ces instants de
découverte semble nous frapper au moment
où on s'y attend le moins
c'est ce que raconte poincaré dans cette
merveilleuse citation je cite au moment
où je mettais le pied sur le marchepied
l'idée me vingt sans que rien dans les
pensées antérieures paru mi avoir
préparé que les transformations dont
j'avais fait usage pour définir les
fonctions fuxéenne était identique à
celle de la géométrie non euclidienne
j'ai pas dit claire samoa mais d'où
vient cette idée d'où vient d'où
viennent les idées mathématiques comment
est ce qu elle se forme
comment se produisent les éclairs et si
on comprend cela pourra tout en
fabriquer en laboratoire
serait-il possible de concevoir des
machines capables de créativité et cette
créativité des machines poids tel un
joueur surpasser la créativité humaine
voilà des questions que je trouve
fascinante et qui ont qui auront occupé
les mathématiciens et les philosophes
pendant des siècles et des millénaires
ce qui est insensé qu'avec les avancées
en algorithmes inc notamment machine
learning
à défaut de réponse on dispose désormais
de spéculation intrigante en particulier
au cours de ces deux années les
intelligences artificielles aussi appelé
ea semble avoir petit à petit
acquis une certaine forme de créativité
dans des domaines comme la peinture la
musique ou l'écriture mais cette espèce
de créativité des machines est elle
comparable à la créativité humaine
et puis d'où vient cette créativité des
machines pour essayer de répondre à ces
questions vous propose de vous
intéresser un petit peu à la technique
on va parler en particulier de l'un des
algorithmes au coeur des intelligences
artificielles d'aujourd'hui à savoir la
descente de gradient stochastique dans
le jargon notamment anglophones ou
l'appelle simplement sgd hésiter c'est
vraiment le coeur le moteur d
intelligence artificielle d'aujourd'hui
en tout cas la plupart d'entre elles
cessent et ce qui l'est c'est ce qui
leur permet d'apprendre et de s'auto
améliorer notamment dans le cadre des
réseaux de neurones et de ce qu'on
appelle le diplôme ning bon ça fait
beaucoup de gros mots ça peut paraître
compliqué et malheureusement c'est pas
simple à expliquer je vais devoir
simplifier je vais devoir vulgariser et
je m'excuse auprès des experts
malheureusement ou pas sgd et assez
compliqué et technique pourtant l'idée
au coeur d'oise et des l'idée
fondamentale de sgt
le principe de base et des est
remarquablement simple d'idées la gdc
que pour attaquer un gros problème
on va d'abord commencer à regarder un
petit morceau du problème pris de façon
au hasard typiquement si le problème est
l'analyse d'une énorme base de données
alors sgd va commencer par tirer au
hasard
une donnée dans l'immense base de
données puis ce café à gdc faire un pas
vers l'explication de cette donnée alors
dit comme ça ça peut paraître bizarre
donc l espace est ce que ce pas a lieu
bien il se trouve que c'est un pas qui a
lieu dans un espèce d espaces d idées or
ça peut être l'espace des preuves
mathématiques ou l'espace des concepts
mathématiques nous encore laissé
l'espace des façons d'assigner une
sémantique
à des objets mater des objets d'étude
bref c'est plus compliqué que c'est
encore ce qu'il faut voir c'est que il
s'agit d'un pas dans un espace jeunesse
un espèce de l'espace des idées et donc
l'idée de s gêner c'est qu'à chaque
étape on va tirer un petit morceau du
problème au hasard et on va effectuer un
pas dans cet espace des idées et ensuite
on va recommencer
on va prendre un autre morceau du
problème et on va faire un pas vers
l'explication de ce morceau du problème
comme vous aurez compris
ensuite on répète cela recommence avec
un autre morceau du problème si vous
fait faire un autre pas depuis on
recommence et on recommence et on
recommence encore et encore en un sens
elle se lève ainsi nous amener dans une
marche aléatoire dont l'espace des idées
alors ce sera pas de n'importe quelle
marche aléatoire
ce sera une marche aléatoire globalement
guidés par le problème que l'on cherche
à résoudre et l'espoir de sgd c'est que
cette marche aléatoire finira par nous
rapprocher d'une solution au problème
alors il ya des cas où l'on peut prouver
que ça va marcher
c'est le cas par exemple des programmes
dits complexes un problème complexe
encore une fois je m'excuse auprès des
puristes c'est un problème dans lequel
les pas de sgd sont garantis d'aller
globalement dans la bonne direction si
le problème est complexe
alors on peut démontrer que sgd finira
par le résoudre les problèmes complexes
en un sens ce sont donc les problèmes
face ils sont aussi les problèmes peu
rocambolesque les problèmes sans
surprise on sait qu'on va y arriver
malheureusement ou pas la plupart des
problèmes ne sont en fait pas convexe la
plupart des problèmes sont beaucoup plus
complexes beaucoup plus rocambolesques
beaucoup plus surprenant on parle de
problèmes dont complexe dans un problème
dont convexe on ne peut même pas
garantir que les pas de sgd iront
globalement dans la bonne direction
un prêtre dont convexe c'est un peu
comme une chaîne de montagnes quand on
fait une marche et à thouars dans cet
espace marche on va dire pas trop
aléatoire la plupart du temps on va
marcher le long de vallée mais il peut
arriver que l'on passe tout à coup d'une
vallée à l'autre que l'on traverse un
col que l'on suit une ligne de crête que
l'on redescende dans un creux qu'on
remonte sur un plateau et qu'on fasse
tout à coup à une falaise les espaces
dont convexe sont des espaces avec très
accidenté avec potentiellement plein de
surprises
typiquement il se peut que derrière la
falaise juste en descendant la falaise
on tombe tout à coup sûr une
merveilleuse forêt vierge encore
inexplorés en ce sens un éclair sa peau
être la descente d'une telle falaise
tout à coup on changera de paysages on
explorerait un nouvel espace encore
inexplorés alors là je prends l'exemple
des montagnes parce que c'est un espace
facile à visualiser c'est une surface de
dimension 2 en tout cas les montagnes
que je connais sauf que l'espace des
idées dans lequel la marche aléatoire de
sgd va avoir lieu ça va être un espace
de très grande dimension
un espace de dimension 3 4 5 % voire
1000 1 million voire même un milliard
voire les espaces de très très grande
dimension
ce sont des espaces très très très
étrange et très contre intuitif par
exemple une propriété des espaces de
très grande dimension
c'est que si on se lance dans une marche
aléatoire dans ces espaces en un sens on
est garantie de se perdre
ce sont de très grands espaces un autre
point étrange de ces espaces et que ce
sont des espaces où il ya énormément de
place y compris à faible distance
il ya énormément de choses à découvrir
tout près de nous il ya énormément d
espace à explorer et donc un éclair sa
peau est la trouvaille d'un objet qu'ils
étaient jeu
à côté de nous mais qui étaient
extrêmement difficiles à trouver
à cause de l'énorme dimensions de
l'espace des idées il se pourrait que ce
soit semble même très probable que ce
soit une combinaison de descente de
falaise et de trouvailles dans des
espaces de très grande dimension qui
auront conduit par exemple alpha go à
effectuer ce fameux coup 37 en 2016
dans une partie de go qui restera
sûrement dans les livres d'histoire
l'intelligence artificielle alpha go
développé par l'entreprise google dit
mind a tout à coup joué un coup
stupéfiants le fameux coup 37
après ce coup le commentateur télé qui
est un expert du jeu de go à d'abord cru
à une erreur de son interprétation des
instructions d'al fagots puis il s'est
mis à croire une erreur d'alpha go mais
après y avoir un petit peu plus réfléchi
on le voit un peu perdu et puis se
rendre compte petit à petit en fait il
s'agissait d'un coup assez brillant
l'adversaire d'alpha go le coréen lee si
dole et plus perdu encore leur revient
d'une pause les tout pâle on le voit
visiblement perdu visiblement effrayée
par la créativité stupéfiante de son
adversaire comme vous le savez sans
doute un fagot finira par triompher de
lys idole mais ce qui est peut être plus
intéressant encore c'est que les joueurs
de go se sont du coup mis à disséquer ce
fameux coup 37 et que ceux ci les a
conduit à repenser ce qu'il croyait
avoir compris du jeu de go ils ont
développé une nouvelle théorie du jeu de
go à partir de ce coup 37
autrement dit les clercs d'un fagot a
révolutionné la théorie du jeu de go ce
point at-il qui en soit de même en
mathématiques en physique en biologie en
médecine voir en sciences en général
voir au delà des sciences peut-être dans
le monde de l'éducation de l'économie de
la finance
ce point est il qu'une intelligence
artificielle est un éclair qui
révolutionne complètement la manière
dont on pense ces domaines
se pratique par exemple qu'une
intelligence artificielle développe une
théorie mathématique qui prouve
l'évidence de l'hypothèse de riemann
laisse pratique que cette théorie
mathématique soit en fait incroyablement
simple et qu'elle bouleverse ce qu'on
croyait avoir compris des mathématiques
peut-être plus intéressant encore se
pourrait-il que sgd en particulier
suffisent à une telle révolution semble
que ce soient des questions très
difficiles et qu'en fait ils soient
extrêmement difficile de dire quoi que
ce soit de nom trivial au sujet de sgd
et ce pour une raison assez simple c'est
que en pratique
sgd répète des millions voire des
milliards voire des millions de
milliards de petits pas d'exploration
or prédire le résultat d'une telle
marche est extrêmement difficile
c'est quelque chose qui avait été
compris par le père de l'intelligence
artificielle et de l'informatique est
l'un des plus grands mathématiciens de
tous les temps le génialissime alan
turing je cite l'idée que les machines
ne peuvent pas conduire à des surprises
est une conséquence je crois d'un
sophisme fallacieux auquel les
philosophe et mathématicien sont
particulièrement sujets j'espère qu'ils
pas trop de philosophe et mathématicien
ici il s'agit de l'hypothèse selon
laquelle dès qu'un fait est présenté à
un esprit toutes les conséquences de ce
fait saute immédiatement à l'esprit de
celui ci cette hypothèse est très utile
dans certains cas mais on oublie trop
facilement qu'elle peut être fausse une
conséquence naturelle de cette façon de
penser
elle qu'on suppose ensuite qu'il n'y a
aucune vertu a simplement calculer les
conséquences des données et des
principes généraux en particulier sgd
chaque pas de sgd et incroyablement
simple incroyablement idiot mais
l'accumulation de millions de milliards
de tels petits pas d'exploration semble
pouvoir conduire à des avancées
spectaculaires et récemment ce fut le
cas en biologie
après avoir développé alpha go
l'entreprise google thilleman à
développer une intelligence artificielle
appelée alpha fold pour s'attaquer au
problème du repliement des protéines
le prince du repliement des protéines
c'est vraiment un des problèmes centraux
de la biologie moléculaire moderne c'est
le problème qui consiste à essayer
d'anticiper la configuration spatiale
d'une protéine à partir de sa séquence
d'acides aminés et ça c'est c'est ultra
important d'une part parce que les
protéines sont partout dans le vivant et
en particulier dans nos cellules
mais aussi parce que les fonctions de
ces protéines dépens de très fortement
des configurations spatiales de ces
protéines de la manière dont elles se
replient dans l'espace 3d
du coup mieux comprendre le repliement
des protéines
c'est ouvrir la porte à des avancées
spectaculaires jusqu'à potentiellement
en biologie et en médecine
or en novembre 2010 huit alpha fund
développé par google dit mind a réussi
la prouesse de surpasser l'humain dans
ce travail de prédiction des
configurations spatiales des protéines
en répétant des éclairs
cette ia pourrait révolutionner ce que
l'on comprend est ce que l'on peut faire
en biologie et en médecine
bref il semble bel et bien que sgd
puisse réussir des prouesses fantastique
des prouesses que les développeurs de
sgd serais bien incapable d'anticiper
mais pour cela à l'instar des
mathématiciens
il semble que sgt doivent d'abord se
perdre dans des réflexions obscur et
sans garantie de succès ce n'est que
dans cette pénombre mystérieuse que les
éclairs pour ont frappé avec une
violence
maxime allemand
[Applaudissements]